[Música]
imagine a seguinte cena
imagine um garotinho sentadinho em
frente à tv esperando o pai chegar no
final do dia para jogar videogame com
ele imagine essa cena ele sentadinho ali
todo entretido olhando a tv olhando
videogame e disse que ele pegue fala pra
amanhã assim mãe que o pai cheio que ela
não chega amanhã pra ele calma calma que
o país já já tá vindo aí continua jogo e
continua em frente o senhor joystick
jogando videogame
aí só que criança criança não desiste
criança não desistia ele olha pra mãe
mãe que obras criadas do país chegam é
que há-de o pai a irmã calma calma
garoto já está chegando calma
alguns minutos depois há ainda escuta o
barulho da porta e eis que abre a porta
e cheguei em casa o derrotado garotinho
sentadinho no chão tremia cruzados
esperando o pai chegar do trabalho
olha pra cima e pergunta pro pai pai não
está vindo pai eo pai olha pra ele e diz
do inferno
agora te pergunta você acha que algum
dia esse garoto vai querer trabalhar
comigo aconteceu algo parecido também
lembro que quando meu filho felipe
felipe estava com 7 anos 7 anos felipe
apareceu para mim com um pacotinho
pequeno pedaço de papel
chegou o pai isso aqui é para te
proteger la no trabalho é mesmo filho
deixa ver e rever peguei aquilo ou lides
embrulhei um papelzinho de pãozinho lei
quando assim que o dezembro lê aquilo na
minha frente tinha uma santa uma
santinha e santos se você perguntar pra
mim
rodrigo que santa é que ela é o fla não
sei
aquela pra mim é a santa do felipe
essa santa ela ela acabou ali virando
uma com grande talismã na minha vida
fiquei pensando depois porque será
aqui felipe me deu esse presente
provavelmente provavelmente ele deve ter
me visto triste chateado e irritado
voltando do trabalho também lembrei de
meu pai meu pai meu pai seu frutuoso
meu pai foi mecânico e um mecânico muito
interessante meu pai era mecânico da
vida não tinha formação aprendeu
aprendeu com a prática tudo na prática e
meu pai eu perdi meu pai muito cedo com
13 anos mas muitas histórias legais
eu guardo aqui no coração histórias que
vieram dele lembro que meu pai e meu pai
tinha uma prática que ele trabalhava
numa oficina mecânica e ele ia todos os
dias trabalhar de social
meu pai a calça social camisa social e
sapato engraxado cabelo bem penteado
todos os dias
um dia ele me levou até a oficina dele
era pequeno bem pequeno levou até a
oficina dele
eis que quando cheguei lá eu percebi que
ele entrou num quartinho
não entendi o que a ele saiu de lá
vestindo uma outra roupa eu sabia o que
era depois que eu fui entender que era
um macacão de mecânicos e investir numa
outra roupa e aí fez o que tinha que
fazer
depois de algum tempo ele voltou para o
quartinho trocou de roupa de novo e tá
todo bonitão
vamos pra casa no meio do caminho quase
chegando em casa lembra que eu perguntei
pra ele pai por que é que o senhor não
saia de casa com aquela roupa que o
senhor colocou lá no naquele quartinho
é mais fácil eu não ganharia tempo aí
ele falou aprenda uma coisa pro teu
trabalho e pra tua família
você só pode mostrar o que é melhor teu
eu não posso chegar em casa todo mal
arrumado e também não posso chegar no
meu trabalho também todo mal cuidado
ali meu pai me deu um grande presente
também me deu um grande presente da
simplicidade dele explicando que
trabalho e família
você pode cuidar com orgulho uma forma
bem simples e extremamente valiosa
minha mãe minha mãe dona cida minha mãe
é uma figura a minha mãe e minha mãe era
costureira também era costureira e aí
ela é uma pessoa muito mas muito
frente muito animada muito positiva
nunca vi minha mãe reclamar de trabalho
nunca vi minha mãe sempre uma visão
otimista da vida a minha mãe é atípica
que hoje depois de muito tempo eu
aprendi uma um termo à minha mãe é
atípica que nós chamamos de gelo tof lá
sim existe gian tof luz e existem os
corais off luz coi só filho gosta de
coisa com o software vai encontrar com
você pelo caminho e vai perguntar fulano
olha tudo bem como são as coisas
ele quer saber das coisas quer saber de
você não se entope hoje em tóquio gosta
de gente de tóquio quer saber quem você
é como você está
de que forma pode ajudar minha mãe era
típica gentofte lá minha mãe hoje eu era
e hoje está com 80 anos minha mãe joga
vôlei e jogar vôlei na minha cidade eu
sou do interior de são paulo em ter uma
cidade chamada itararé do interior de
são paulo
minha mãe já foi presidente do clube da
terceira idade ela por várias vezes
outro dia ela chegou pra mim e falou
assim filho você que tem lido e com as
faculdades
será que você não conversava com eles
porque as meninas estão querendo
aprender informática as menina ea mãe
também me deu vários presentes assim de
que é possível sim trabalhar gostando de
gente trabalhar de forma positiva
eu na minha carreira tive a oportunidade
de desenvolver uma pesquisa desenvolveu
um experimento em busca das melhores
práticas de feedback as melhores
práticas ou seja se quem faz feedback
como faz e como faz pra fazer bem feito
fizemos uma grande uma grande
investigação para descobrir essas
melhores práticas e alguns pontos muito
importantes aparecendo e desses pontos
que eu quero contar pra vocês aqui hoje
é um ponto fundamental para se trabalhar
bem com o feedback é porque não
considerarmos um feedback como um grande
presente sim por ser presente como
presente
você vai ter que fazer de uma forma
diferente você tem que agir de forma
diferente porque para você dar um
presente para uma pessoa que
ida para você dar um presente uma pessoa
que você admira você primeiro precisa
conhecer a pessoa precisa conhecer ela
precisa saber o que ela gosta quais são
os hábitos dela precisa saber o que ela
precisa o que é útil para ela
assim também é um feedback o feedback
tem que dar algo pra ela que seja útil
para ela me fez lembrar uma outra
história uma história o meu felipe o meu
filho quando felipe tinha um aninho 11 1
aninho eu dei pra ele de presente um
autorama pra ele
lembro dessa cena que na sala
montamos aquela pista enorme e ficamos
olhando ali ele sentadinho no meu colo o
carrinho passava o bumbum e ele olhava
nem sabia para onde eu olhava no
carrinho presente pra ele aí nada ela
presente para o pai que queria ter tido
aquele brinquedo não teve muitos chefs
fazem assim muitos pais também dão
sermões enormes em forma de feedback
na verdade não era nem para aquelas
pessoas era só para satisfazer o ego
dele ou dela de ter dito aquilo
fala um monte de coisas na verdade não
tinha utilidade praticamente alguma um
presente tem que ser algo útil um
presente e tente algo importante e nesse
sentido nesse sentido o presente ele se
torna algo extremamente valiosos
extremamente valioso quando você começa
a considerá lo como um feedback algo que
a pessoa precisa de verdade quer ver
embalagem a embalagem ela é muito
valiosa presente você tão presentes em
embalagens como se estivesse sem alma
sem vida
tem gente que coloca os laço é perfume
na embalagem
a embalagem aqui nesse sentido
representará forma a forma como o
feedback é dado para alguém eu posso te
dizer a mesma coisa com as mesmas
palavras de um jeito que construa e
posso te dizer a mesma coisa com as
mesmas palavras com jeito que te destrói
veja está na forma
nesse sentido eu prego a vocês que não
existe feedback positivo ou negativo
existe a forma positiva ea forma
negativa
preste atenção na forma como você está
falando com as pessoas é é isso é
extremamente importante o quanto que
realmente se ela precisa a embalagem que
vai ser utilizada você precisa se
preparar pra dar feedback para alguém
lhes estudar isso antes não pode ser
feito de qualquer forma a mesma coisa
por um presente
você vai para uma festa você tem que se
preparar antes pra ir pra festa não pode
de qualquer forma tem que ter uma
preparação presente também tem hora
certa data certa para entregar tem
presentes têm presentes que são lindos
se entregues ao vivo em público tem
presentes que são íntimos só você ea
pessoa precisa saber mais ninguém
assim é o feedback do elogio o elogio é
um presente que tem que ser feito em
público não lhe é um presente que tem
que ser tratado em público
já uma crítica é uma crítica ela é sim
um presente um feedback precisa ser
feito de forma reservada em um ritual
específico jeito específico não precisa
de plateia uma crítica é um feedback que
não precisa de plateia o local certo é o
jeito certo o time certo time certo para
entregar um feedback também é muito
importante me fez lembrar uma outra
história
lembro que outro dia nessas minhas
andanças pelo país cheguei eu cheguei um
dos de um hotel na entrada do hotel
estava uma bandeira enorme dizendo hoje
festival de risotos e wes adoro risotos
subi correndo fui lá tomar meu banho de
se ir já fui direto com o restaurante do
hotel
eis que quando eu chego gente cheguei já
fui recepcionado imediatamente pelo chef
pelo estava responsável pelo evento
ele chegou sujeito chegou me entrevistou
ali meia dúzia de perguntas aí falou
assim para mim já sei já sei o risoto
que vou fazer com o senhor
o paa a filha chorar aguarde por favor
que eu já vou trazer a sua mesa
eu sentei com uma criança esperando um
brinquedo e iraque alguns minutos chega
o chefe trazendo nas mãos à obra de arte
dele chegou chegou ao meu lado e me
colocou pra tua minha frente eu falei
nossa saque imediatamente tirei uma foto
pra pôr no instagram fiquei todo feliz e
ele começou a explicar pra mim os
ingredientes que ele utilizou no risoto
começou a explicar e eu não agüentei
gente eu confesso a vocês não aguentei
peguei o carro de uma porção mandei lá
pra dentro da boca aquilo estava
queimando estava muito quente muito
quente só que aí olhava pra cima olhava
pra ele não podia tirar aquilo da boca
aqui estava queimando na boca do meu
lado me explicando num não estava ali
aguardando
eis que do nada começa a escorrer uma
lágrima começa com uma lágrima e olhou
para o lado e pensar nossa se cada
gostava mesmo de vizzotto tá chorando
aí vem o outro aprendizado sobre o
feedback pra mim se o assunto é muito
quente
espere esfriar com uma pelas beiradas
cuidado você vai queimar a língua
mas esse é um feedback tem que ser dado
só escolha a hora certa
escolha a hora certa assim você vai se
queimar
kurt e essa entrega extremamente
importante a forma de entregar e curtir
a festa curtir a festa
se você entregou seu presente precisa e
podia festa entregou o presente uma
pessoa que você foi até a festa dela
você precisa curtir a mesma coisa um
feedback
se você deu o seu feedback para alguém
vir a página
vida que segue tem chefes e tem pais que
adoram fazer isso voltam volta ou
repetidas vezes no mesmo assunto dias
depois é muito chato isso não ensina
nada e fica volts
voltando ao assunto se você tá voltando
no assunto você não tá curtindo a festa
você não entregou seu presente ainda que
ainda não entregou o presente o presente
é algo valioso íssimo extremamente
valioso e nessa toda essa pesquisa é bem
realizando um dos itens que apareceram
em todos é os melhores práticas melhores
práticas em realização de feedbacks são
pessoas extremamente habilidosas em
escuta e não em fala está na escuta a
chave é saber escutar é a chave
mas e aí porque tantas pessoas erram
para escutar existe uma diferença muito
grande entrar entre os verbos ouvir e
escutar ouvir é diz respeito à
capacidade auditiva de captar os sons
escutar ea nossa habilidade de captar
esses sons e transformar em algo
relevante ou seja a escuta para escuta
existe esforço existe esforço da crede
emocional esforço intelectual tem um
outro dado importante
um dado muito importante que diz que o
nosso nossa capacidade de pensamento
corre quatro vezes mais rápido que a
nossa capacidade de fala ou seja o
sujeito leva um minuto para contar algo
que o cérebro do outro levou 15 segundos
para interpretar adivinha o que acontece
com aqueles 45 segundos restantes
nós somos inundados de pensamentos de
preconceitos de julgamentos e ali
paramos de escutar
rubem alves cunhou uma frase maravilhosa
dizendo que é na escuta que o amor
começa e ela não escuta que o amor
termina e aí eu te pergunto então por
que você evita amar as pessoas que estão
ao seu lado porque você evita a março a
equipe porque você fica inundado com
distrações e não escuta teus filhos
porque bom feedback e escuta tem tudo a
ver o meu filho hoje está com 22 anos
continua meu grande professor continua
eu continuou pisando na bola com ele
bastante e ele o tempo
tudo me ensinando a pegar feedbacks
feedback da vida com ele
a santa à santa que ele me deu à santa
que ele me deu ele continua comigo aqui
santa que ele me deu até hoje onde eu
vou ela me acompanha na mesa do meu
escritório onde eu estou cada empresa
que estou levo minha santa junto é aí
ela fica ali na mesa a cada momento que
eu me pego irritado nervoso preocupado
eu olho pra ela e ela me faz respirar de
novo
convido todos vocês por um grande
movimento
imagine imagine um mundo em que os
filhos possam aprender em casa a escutar
com os pais
imagine um mundo em que as escolas
ensinem escuta assim como ensinam
disciplinas como matemática química
física
imagine um mundo em que os gestores
discutem suas equipes e seus clientes
tornando ambientes melhores para se
trabalhar e tornando ambientes melhores
também para fazer negócios
imagine um mundo imagine um mundo onde
os governantes sejam escolhidos não só
sobre a sua capacidade de fala mais
sobre a sua capacidade de escuta
nós precisamos de uma revolução
convido todos vocês para essa revolução
para essa revolução do que eu chamo de a
era da escuta
nós precisamos nos dedicarmos mais as
pessoas
temos mais interesse genuíno e atento
sobre o outro
convido a todos vocês a esse movimento
pegue esse presente esse feedback pra
você eu tenho certeza que o futuro será
incrível muito obrigado
[Aplausos]